[Música]
a votar não chorou mas eu sou médico nem
como dizer mas pior seu médico
otorrinolaringologista é um nome difícil
mas otorrinolaringologista são médicos
que são bem freqüentadas é todos todos
vocês aqui provavelmente já passaram por
um médico otorrinolaringologista
mas pra falar dessa história hoje uma
história de luz uma história de medicina
tem que falar de mim né
então esse sou eu em 1979
sou mais ou menos velho super 8 é com
meu pai na sala tocando música então a
inspiração para o rio para a audição
veio desde essa época ea gente como
médico a gente tem uma responsabilidade
muito grande porque o que a gente faz
com o paciente e principalmente nós que
somos cirurgiões
o que a gente faz com que o paciente se
não fosse com consentimento do paciente
e esse é um crime em qualquer lugar do
mundo a gente vai pegar uma faca vai
cortar a pegar uma broca vai perfurar
vai tirar coisa ancar suturar imagina se
isso não tivesse o consentimento do
paciente mas pra gente está aqui hoje a
gente teve que ter todos os ensinamentos
dos grandes professores dos grandes
mestres do passado mas a medicina é uma
história basicamente de luz e uma
história é basicamente de uso de
instrumentos
veja esse quadro esse quadro de um
pintor que chama luffield de 1822 ao ano
da independência do brasil que vê em um
médico o nome do quadro chamou um médico
de doctor tem uma criança que que o
médico sabe que vai morrer o pai da
criança está perto da janela ea mãe da
criança está inconsolável
mas mesmo sabendo que a criança vai
morrer o médico tenta encontrar na luz
no seu pensamento alguma forma de
conseguir minimizar esse sofrimento da
família ninja minimizar o sofrimento
dessa mãe mas claro depois vieram os
instrumentos tão o estetoscópio foi um
dos primeiros instrumentos a serem
utilizados para que a gente pudesse
escutar os batimentos do nosso coração
escutar a respiração do nosso pulmão e
tentar fazer diagnóstico que antes eram
muito complicado muito difícil de fazer
mas a medicina é basicamente a história
da luz e tem uma frase muito bonita que
me tocou muito quando eu conheci a
cidade viena na áustria que diz assim
tem um museu chamamos o den2 copia disse
que não existe cirurgia difícil o que
tenha pouca luz e pouca exposição então
se você conseguir colocar luz e colocar
e conseguisse povo você vai conseguir
fazer qualquer tipo de procedimento
qualquer tipo de cirurgia ea história da
nossa especialidade da
otorrinolaringologia basicamente a
história de colocar luz em cavidades na
boca e no nariz no nosso ouvido é tanto
que o símbolo da otorrino por muito
muito tempo não era um otoscópio não era
um estetoscópio não era um microscópio
mas era assim um foco frontal e veja
antigamente essa é uma cirurgia feita
não tinha luvas não tinha bactéria na
época o pessoal não acreditava na
anestesia local com cocaína e então
servia o procedimento era feito
ambulatorial sem anestesia geral sem
muita segurança
é um procedimento que era muito rápido
senão a cirurgia que chama de septo
parte aquela do teu desvio de septo
outro o coreto grande né então essas
cirurgias eram feitas de uma forma bem é
primitiva e bem interessante mas a
história da luz também é uma história
universal ea história da primeira
universidade do mundo que o que é uma
história de bolonha na itália é a
história é basicamente da luz de colocar
luz e ter os instrumentos e na
universidade de bolonha legal porque tem
o túmulo de grandes mestres da medicina
como professor antonio mario ao salvar o
professor hope e esse é o seu momento do
professor val sabe o professor valsalva
interessante que ele foi um dos
primeiros cirurgiões de ouvido se vê que
tem quatro anjinhos nesse túmulo um dos
anjinhos e tinha uma faca segurava uma
faca e estava segurando um ouvido então
ele foi um dos primeiros cirurgiões de
ouvido e por conta disso ele conseguiu
desenvolver tratados conseguiu
desenvolver livros que são utilizados
até hoje e técnicas cirúrgicas que são
utilizadas até hoje com uma técnica da 1
mas toy da economia então a cirurgia de
ouvido que a gente faz quando a pessoa
tem aquelas otites crônicas ou quando
tem um mocinho que chama colete a thomas
o nome difícil é desenvolvido está
vazando está superando a pessoa vai
perdendo a audição ea cirurgia e demais
torre que a gente faz hoje a mastectomia
feita basicamente com microscópio esse
aqui é o professor chute foi pra pessoa
um alemão que quem standard usou a
técnica da cirurgia
adamastor diz e aqui você vê era feito
antigamente com escopo com martelo isso
o paciente acordado você imagina como
era o procedimento
eu pegava um martelo para parecer um
carpinteiro né pra abrir o osso da mas
todd para treinar que ele pudesse fazer
todos aqueles tipos de procedimentos só
que a medicina evoluiu a tecnologia
evoluiu e hoje a gente tem instrumentos
um microscópio cirúrgico tem brocas
trios que a gente chama esse microscópio
é bem utilizado ea técnica clássica
técnica tradicional agora nada disso de
cirurgia teria de votar teria evoluído
se a gente não tivesse por trás as
técnicas anestésicas e esse é o quadro
da primeira pesquisa que foi feita em 16
de outubro de 1846 lá em boston em
massachusetts e e se esse lugar ainda
existe o twitter do mundo você pode
visitar e aqui está aquele quadro né
você vê que naquele quadro tinha um
médico fazendo anestesia não quer um
dentista na verdade todos os mortos
tinham cirurgião e tinha a esse senhor
que é meu pai
ele não é tão velho assim né mas ele
estava lá presente em 1846 né
o pessoal pergunta legal você ter seu
pai anestesista minha esposa também
anestesista sabe fazer anestesia pra
minha ideia é legal mas de vez em quando
eles dão pitacos sabe quando esse
negócio dá pitaco na net na cirurgia é
esse meu pai e minha esposa não posso
nem mandar calar a boca né
é complicado né mas também estava lá e
minha esposa né anestesista e assim o
pessoal pergunta é legal você fazer
anestesia com sua esposa e tal de gum
excelente é um excelente arranque talvez
a melhor na entrevista que existem no
estado do ceará é ruim também tem o seu
problema nem aí com o problema que ela
fala muita mulher né
aí eu fui pra ela fala muito na cirurgia
você tem que se concentrar de vez em
quando para fazer alguns procedimentos
ea pessoa pode estar perturbando né
você pode calar a boca né foi um erro um
erro mortal passou uma semana no sofá
domingo por conta disso aí eu colocar
uma câmera escondida uma câmera
escondida no centro cirúrgico que está
filmando ela entendeu pra provar que ela
falava muito e mostrou um vídeo pra ele
quando mostrei pra levar duas semanas no
sofá
tão bem complicado eu estou mostrando
agora pra mil pessoas já fizeram o sofá
já deixei meu amor vou dormir no sofá
te amo eu tenho certeza que eu passar
seis meses não só agora mas bem
agitava a thaísa anestesista gente tava
fazendo a cirurgia no hospital público e
os hospitais públicos aqui no brasil
infelizmente eles não são tão bem
equipadas e agente um microscópio bem
antigo ninho uma marca bem antigo hino
nacional que tinha uma luz que de vez em
quando essa luiz queimava
só que a gente sabia quando a luz ea
queimar a gente sabia como trocar luz
apagava a cirurgia trocava luz e
voltaram a fazer a cirurgia não tava lá
eu fazendo a cirurgia urgente tipo não
pode fechar uma perfuração timpânica à
luz do microscópio boa e talking
queimando de microscopia agora o que
fazer
a gente tem um ditado não quer que o pt
está cagado né
então eu disse natasha era enfermeira
traz à luz reserva né a ela taxa de
shuttle esquecemos de comprar não tinha
de café como você deixou de marcar
cirurgias não tinha luz seu término a
cirurgia faz qualquer coisa aí o conduto
do do cidadão era bem grande sabe eu
tentei eu pus aquele foco frontal aquela
luiz tenta enxergar não conseguia ver
nada
aí o anestesista nesta existem esposa
disse por que você não põe um endoscópio
endoscópio gente usa a cirurgia de nariz
habilitem 4
minha primeira resposta que não cabe a
ela você já tentou nunca tentei o que
não tem feito pra quem tá ligado
eu peguei o windows natasha traz 12
copos torneio só colocar o windows cop
quando eu vi aquela imagem anatomia toda
é muito melhor tem mais no microscópio e
consegui terminar a cirurgia muito mais
rápido e isso é bem mais efetivo do que
se tivesse fazendo a cirurgia com um
microscópio
então quando terminou a cirurgia já tô
com dor de barriga vou pra casa imagina
eu tava e morava em são paulo e sabe que
eu fui de santo amaro até mais ou menos
avenida paulista numa sexta feira à
tarde
imagina os quatro horas pensando
maquinando será que eu sou o único dos
oito que colocou endoscópio ouvido então
foi na internet no médico dos médicos
quando togo e fui investigar se tinha
alguém fazendo isso e achei os trabalhos
de um médico do bairro chão mas árabes
baixei os trabalhos e comecei a lei e
toda a vida que você publica um trabalho
científico
com isso o contato endereço o correio o
e mail essas coisas aí manda um email
pra ele não conhecia ele nunca tinha
ouvido falar da vida dele o médico lá do
bairro voltar beijo eu sou inglês né
sou um jovem cirurgião brasileiro tenham
feitas muitas cirurgias tinha feito um
jogo tenho feito muitas cirurgias
endoscópicas de ouvido e queria conhecer
o serviço está para ver como é melhor
aí ele respondeu né o erro dele foi ter
respondido só você pode vim aqui pra
dubai vai ter um curso no omã banco vai
ter um custo romã e você vai ser meu
convidado a gente faz parte do curso se
dissesse alguma coisa tá lá fui eu né
pro omã um país do oriente médio não é
muçulmano e levei a doutora anestesista
da minha esposa também nesse concurso a
gente encontrou outros outras pessoas
que estavam fazendo com esses dois
italianos que o professor daniel marcone
professor lívio preso de bolonha e de
verona ea gente começou um grupo que
chama grupo internacional de cirurgia
endoscópica de ouvido
quando a gente sair a adutora tae sae
também com a gente tá a gente ia jantar
só que eu passava o dia mais ou menos na
universidade fazendo curso as decepções
de taís vai conhecer a cidade mas kate é
uma cidade que foi fundada por
portugueses têm história tão forte
português e tal eu passo o dia na
universidade se conhece nossas forças
legais quando chega de noite estava dia
10 mostra as fotos e tem essa foto do
hotel da sacada do hotel de que é isso
se você não conhecer a cidade não foi
pra não não eu tentei fui no taxista o
taxista chegou à casa de seu marido
então quando vou levar o dinheiro ao
país né
mas em dubai que é mais liberal então a
gente conseguir se divertir ela foi o
deserto é um de cabelo e quase levou à
queda levou o espírito do caminho e tal
aquela coisa me vestir de cheia que tal
só não gosta de duas mulheres é claro
tinha amor mas a gente começou a
publicar publicamos os primeiros livros
participamos dos primeiros cursos nos
estados unidos na europa e no japão
sempre a mesma ladainha até que a gente
foi convidado para ser professor lar de
harvard que como o do título geral falou
errado da vida
o aparelho nada o que faz a universidade
são as pessoas o que faz a medicina não
é o hospital são os médicos não vão
operar no albert einstein beleza é
melhor vc operar no jf foi o médico
melhor que o médico foi operar no albert
einstein né
então isso é interessante isso aqui a
foto do primeiro curso mas alguns livros
que que a gente a publicou mais uma
coisa interessante a saúde ela não tem
preço mas ela tem custo
isso é uma coisa muito interessante que
a gente médico e vocês pacientes têm que
compreender e no final do dia alguém vai
pagar a conta quer seja você pagando
diretamente ao médico paga no seu plano
de saúde quer seja o governo através dos
impostos que são cobrados que você então
alguém vai pagar a conta toda a vida que
a gente incluir tecnologia nova na
medicina diferentemente das outras áreas
por exemplo tem uma fábrica de fazer
carro
se você for um roubo na fábrica de fazer
carros e diminui o custo final de
produção na medicina toda a vida que
você põe um material novo em tecnologia
nova você aumenta o custo final
essa cirurgia é diferente é uma das
poucas cirurgias que você está incluindo
tecnologia e está diminuindo o custo
final a da medicina então isso é um
avanço para todo o sistema de saúde pra
gente porque você consegue ver melhor
você consegue estudar melhor
mas claro né sempre tem aquele negócio
da anestesia e eu como star wars é né
sempre procurando à luz essa história de
luz
a gente está procurando receber a
doutora exista lá né
é o lado negro da força para suspender
ou não sabe lusa
cuidado complicado sempre pra você ser
complicado mas claro né 11 gw chegando
para fazer a cirurgia no centro
cirúrgico né
mas claro né também tenho das feita né
ele vem pra tentar interromper cirurgias
e não oscilam série não usa essa técnica
é a técnica funciona pra nada né
mas claro existem outras pessoas que
podem ajudar a rede mas essa técnica me
deu a possibilidade também de conhecer o
mundo de praga cidade por exemplo não é
brincadeira não mas ontem ontem eu
estava no vietnã
então a coisa já fui pra ainda na índia
né a minha esposa não gosto quando com
essas fotos de mulheres mas nada de
especial
isso é ver que toda a vida que a gente
faz os cursos faz na índia é tão
interessante que você tem que acender
uma vela para os antepassados e
desrespeitam muito a família respeitam
muito os antepassados você tem que isso
aqui no centro cirúrgico fazendo
cirurgias ao vivo e uma coisa que me
chamou a atenção no centro da cidade
tinha essa placa aqui ó no speedy ou
seja não vale os pinos e hoje meu melhor
isso é bem interessante né mas foi uma
técnica que que tá beneficiando os
pacientes que foi criada aqui no ceará
ou seja do nordeste no brasil onde o
pessoal pensa que não existe medicina
mas é onde na verdade existe uma das
melhores medicinas que é praticada hoje
no brasil que está no mundo
então nós temos médicos aqui
extremamente competentes temos hospitais
extremamente baixos e fazemos a
diferença pra vocês para os pacientes
têm uma técnica que é menos invasiva tem
uma técnica muito mais segura do que as
técnicas tradicionais tendo a
possibilidade de preservar onde até
mesmo melhorar a audição das pessoas e
hoje até brinquedos o assunto quem quer
é o que não nunca fazer cirurgia
você vê que você conhece já o país a
falta do canal que não pode mostrar que
está sem camiseta cv professor prejudica
agora sempre como toda técnica cirúrgica
sempre tem as resistências
principalmente nas pessoas que não
querem fazer essa tecla não acho legal
mas tem uma frase legal do filósofo que
chama até o shopping hours o alemão ele
diz que toda a verdade
ela passa por três estágios primeiro ela
é equalizar nessa não ser aprovada
é coisa de doido aqui do lado do ceará e
tal segundo ela é violentamente a aposta
não pode fazer se você fizesse aqui você
vai ser expulso de cirurgia e tal mas
depois ela é aceita como é evidente e
isso a gente viu em 2009 quando a gente
apresentou se pela primeira vez no
congresso americano de otorrino country
instituindo mundo ano pode ser só um
louco total em 2013 essas mesmas pessoas
que o congresso de vancouver essas
mesmas pessoas que disseram que a
cirurgia endoscópica acho que faço isso
faz uns dez anos eu faço isso é muito
legal sérgio guerra é interessante
então pra finalizar eu gosto de mostrar
esse vídeo sic o roubo não foi um
argentino na mercedes no grande prêmio
de fórmula 1 de adelaide de 1954 cv
drive e uma largada de uísque e cachaça
é pra dirigir um carro que não tinha
capacete não tinha cinto de segurança
não tinha remédio não tinha nada a ver
um pit stop bem primitivo você tinha um
mecânico para tirar os pneus para tirar
as coisas e demoravam né perdia quase um
minuto ou dois minutos fazendo um pit
stop o piloto lá com esse capacete que
não se vê nada e é interessante que tem
um mercado que fica só limpando o pára
brisa mas não tinha para abrir o pára
brisa cara do piloto né
aí depois de um minuto vai sair o carro
e agora vamos ver a mesma coisa 2014
fernando alonso na ferrari a mesma coisa
mesmo pit stop o que a gente faz da
cirurgia endoscópica de ouvido a mesma
coisa que os cirurgiões tradicionais
fazem só que a gente faz mais rápido faz
melhor e faz mais barato o paciente
muito obrigado pessoal
[Música]
[Aplausos]